hello everyone
excited to see you today we're going to
be hearing from David Q on Jupiter AI
David's contact information will be
available in the slides and he'll also
be out in the hallway in case you have
any questions thank you
all right well hello everybody my name
is David Q I'm a software engineer at
AWS and today I'm here to talk to you
about a Jupiter AI which is a Jupiter
extension that brings generative AI to
Jupiter
so in this talk we will cover first of
all what exactly is Jupiter Ai and then
we'll showcase some of the features that
Jupiter AI offers specifically the magix
interface and a collaborative chat panel
in Jupiter lab we'll also highlight one
of the key features that Jupiter AI
offers which is the ability to actually
question files using local retrieval
augmented generation and finally we will
conclude the segment with the takeaways
so here today you will learn how Jupiter
AI can help you provide uh code insights
like explaining code and understanding
what's actually going on in a notebook
we'll also talk about how jupyter AI can
help you debug failing code so for
example you have a notebook and it fails
and it produces this horribly long Trace
stack and it's very indecipherable we
will discuss how jupy AI can help with
that Jupiter AI provides this General
interface for interaction and
experimentation with the currently
available language models and also even
let you collaborate with other peers and
in AI simultaneously in Jupiter lab and
again it will the Jupiter AI also allows
you to ask questions about local files
which we will demo later
so first segment what is Jupiter AI
well Jupiter AI is an official project
Jupiter extension for generative Ai and
it's part of the Jupiter lab subproject
on GitHub Jupiter AI provides interfaces
for model interaction
and to dispel any misconceptions Jupiter
AI itself is not a language model we did
not pay thousands upon thousands of
dollars to train our own language model
but instead Jupiter AI is a human AI
interface for for Jupiter
so to begin I want to talk about some of
the Big Ideas surrounding Jupiter AI
these ideas that we have been thinking
in our head since the Inception and the
development of Jupiter Ai and why is
another AI ID integration necessary I
mean this space is very very moves very
fast and there are there are other tools
like GitHub copilot out there so why
Jupiter AI
so the first principle the first big
idea of Jupiter AI is that we wanted
Jupiter AI to be vendor agnostic Jupiter
AI should not have a bias towards one
specific model or a model vendor so for
example we should not lock the user into
using exclusively open AI models but
instead allow models from other
third-party providers such as AI 21
anthropic cohere
Etc
Jupiter AI also needs to be transparent
and traceable the user should always be
able to see exactly what prompts are
being sent to the model and furthermore
these need to be traceable like they
need to be logged somewhere and captured
and a lot of aiid Integrations don't
offer that to a lot of these
Integrations today are just essentially
black boxes that are that don't have any
transparency or traceability
Jupiter AI also needs to be
collaborative
um so I'm not sure how many of you keep
up with the recent developments in
Jupiter lab but the latest release of
Jupiter Lab 3 and Jupiter lab 4 support
real-time collaboration very similar to
Google Docs so multiple users can
connect you to the same notebook and
edit it simultaneously and execute cells
and Jupiter AI needs to have to keep
that in mind to keep the multi-user
scenario in mind how do you coordinate
multiple users and an AI simultaneously
Jupiter AI also needs
exclusively prompted and let me
elaborate on this the models should not
be run without without user input user
input needs to happen before jupyter AI
runs any code it before it sends a
prompt to a model and just for just for
safety purposes right it should not be
running a model continuously in a
background that would also be very
expensive
and finally Jupiter ai's user interface
needs to be human centered it needs to
communicate
so humans communicate through a lot more
modalities than just text and I think
that a lot of the limitations
surrounding language model research is
the simple fact that humans don't
communicate exclusively through text
they communicate visually and the user
interface needs to be designed with that
in mind and I I will show exactly what I
mean by this and later in the
presentation
so the first feature that Jupiter AI
offers are Jupiter AI magics so first of
all what are magics well magix and
IPython are basically special commands
that execute code when they are
evaluated in an IPython kernel so the
line magic syntax basically is a single
percent sign followed by the command
name then all of the arguments and that
is a single line command the multi-line
command which we call a cell magic
requires two percent signs the command
name and then the rest of the arguments
can be on the same line or any
subsequent lines so it's kind of
analogous to a command line interface
that is native to IPython so here in the
screenshot there I'm running the history
magic command which as as properly named
shows you the history of these uh
commands that you have run in IPython
and when you execute that cell that's
the output that's shown below
[Applause]
so why Jupiter AI Magics
um a lot I know a lot of members in this
audience haven't even heard of IPython
Magics beforehand
so the problem now is that users need to
experiment with multiple models but they
don't have a unified interface for model
interaction so if you want to use a
model if you want to compare the outputs
of a model from AI 21 and cohere and uh
or like or a model on hugging face
each of these model providers has a
different SDK and a different rest API
it's actually surprisingly difficult to
get everything working and that's not
even to mention the issues with
authentication and authorization
so to work around this users are
experimenting today in online web
playgrounds like just like chat GPT
right
chat.openai.com but the problem with
these is that they don't really produce
a reproducible or shareable artifact to
collaborate with other developers right
like all to to send the prompts and
outputs to another developer you either
have to copy and paste them or you just
take a screenshot and send it to them
there's no reproducible or shareable
artifact that's produced and when you
create a new session in your web
playground everything is lost right
and Jupiter AI solves these problems
with a surprisingly simple interface
that can be used in any IPython context
and by python context this includes
Jupiter notebooks Jupiter lab vs code
and Google collab
so to install the extension uh just
install it via pip
um the square brackets indicate that
you want to install all of the optional
dependencies for all of the model
providers and one thing I want to
highlight here is that Jupiter AI is
modular extensible and multi-vendor so
it supports multiple language models for
multiple vendors right out of the box
and again this works with an Nei python
context including jupyter notebooks so
there are two installation commands one
is the top one
is if you want to install everything all
at once and this includes the chat panel
that is part of the Jupiter lab
extension but for users who live
exclusively in IPython you can also
install it in a separate package called
Jupiter AI magix which doesn't include a
lab extension and any of the client-side
web interface stuff
and to load the extension it's really
simple use the load extension magic
command really nice and you can also do
a load extension Jupiter AI magix
and the first step here is to
authenticate with a model provider and
there are a couple of ways of doing so
um one way to do it when starting is to
do it when starting the server by
passing it as an environment variable so
each model provider
expects a certain authentic
authentication token that can be passed
as an environment variable so this can
be done either by adding it to your
shell profile or passing it in line on
server start so for example here there's
a environment variable called anthropic
API key which you might imagine allows
you to work with models from anthropic
um there's also a way to do this without
action without having to open a terminal
at all in notebooks so you can also use
the uh the end
IPython magic to set an environment
variable inside your inside your
notebook the issue with this is that
it's a little bit of a security risk
because you could be persisting your
token and a document that may be shared
with your colleagues so please make sure
to do to delete the cell afterwards to
avoid exposing your credentials
and to get started it the Jupiter AI
offers the appropriately named AI cell
magic so the first line contains all the
arguments all the subsequent lines are
the prompt and the only required
argument that goes in a first line is
the provider id and the model ID
delimited by a colon so here
I'm doing double percent AI anthropic
Cloud V 1.2 and what this is saying is
call the cloud V 1.2 model provided by
anthropic and the prompt is please write
a haiku about Jupiter and here you can
see it does actually write a haiku about
Jupiter which is very nice
so to invoke a model
I I did want to elaborate on the syntax
a little bit so to invoke a model
you need to pass both a provider id and
a model ID and the the key idea here is
that providers are like interfaces for
one or more models and they're usually
restricted to the models of a single
parent company so for example the
anthropic provider as you might guess
only provides models from anthropic and
here I've broken down to syntax a little
bit more just to be really really
explicit here the provider is anthropic
the model ideas Cloud B 1.2
the AI IPython magic also supports the
list subcommand which is done by percent
AI list and this actually lists the
Avail currently available models on your
instance
so here you can see uh at the very first
row you can see that
the first row is the AI 21 provider and
the next column represents the
environment variable that specific
provider expects so here you can see
that in order to use AI 21 models you
need to pass the AI 21 API key and the
third column is a very helpful column
that just tells you if it's set in your
current environment so if you see all
green you're good if you see a red X
there's uh you need to provide the
environment variable and finally the
last column lists all of the models that
you can use so here you can see in AI 21
you can use J1 large J1 Grand
etc etc there's a lot of them and same
for a cohere open AI
Etc one thing I did want to highlight
here is that some providers cannot
actually list all of their models
because there is an extraordinary number
of them I think the best example of this
is hugging face Hub where if you look at
the row for hugging face Hub you will
see that in the models column it says
this provider does not find a list of
models that's because hiking face has an
extremely large number of models and
there's no way to possibly list all of
them in a single viewable table
and in this case the model ID for
hugging face Hub is the repo ID so for
example gpt2 or Google forward slash
flan t5xl
and here we already have an immediate
use case
um which is to rapidly test llms so
again
um testing multiple language models from
different vendors is actually a bit of a
surprisingly tricky problem and Jupiter
AI helps provide a declarative interface
for doing so and also allows you to
leverage existing shortcuts built into
Jupiter notebook and Jupiter lab so here
if I wanted to compare the outputs of
three different models that
traditionally would have involved me
required me to write some python code
that actually calls the hugging face Hub
inference API but instead I can just
create three cells in a notebook command
a shift enter boom and then they all run
and I can easily immediately just
compare the outputs of these language
models and determine which one I would
want for my application so shamelessly I
have my examples include an Endor are
trying to get these models to generate
the most effective marketing for a AWS
even though I'm at a Microsoft
conference I have no shame
um so here so you can imagine like I am
a machine learning engineer I'm trying
to find the best model to generate
marketing for AWS and again I can do
this super easily with Jupiter AI I just
run all these cells compare the outputs
and determine which one that I like the
most probably the first one ironically
from Google not from Amazon
um
the next feature of Jupiter AI Magics is
output formatting so
this circles back to that human-centered
design idea that I had talked about
earlier which is that language models
generate exclusively text but humans
don't exclusively communicate through
text humans can communicate visually
through like different modalities
so here with output formatting you can
actually visualize the output of a
language model and a lot of people
didn't even know that different language
models can generate text in different
formats because because of a lack of
visualization tooling so for example
here in the very first image up above
I'm telling the cloud V 1.2 model to
generate a square with using SVG with a
black five pixel border and a white fill
and when I run that cell to my surprise
it actually renders the uh it actually
renders the square because I explicitly
specified via the format argument that
the output will be in HTML format so
Jupiter is actually able to render that
visually
um language models can also output law
Tech this is a pretty unknown feature of
a lot of language models but they can
they can output law Tech too so with the
uh Dash F math uh argument I can specify
that this this language model will
output law Tech markup that represents a
math equation and Jupiter should render
it accordingly so here I'm telling the
uh this uh latest and greatest AI 21
model generate me the Schrodinger
equation
um
and it actually it actually does so
correctly by the way
um very nice
and there's also visual capability for
Json so here I'm asking chat GPT
generate an example AWS cdk Json file
and Jupiter does provide a native
renderer for Json files to help allow
developers to explore Json trees rather
than just receiving a massive block of
unformatted Json text
and the key idea here is that this
feature really encourages users to push
language models Beyond just simple plain
text generation and try to get it to
generate other output formats
Jupiter AI also supports IPython
interpolation so if you set a variable
named uh in this case poet I'm assigning
a string Walt Whitman to the variable
poet and any syntax token wrapped in
curly braces will automatically get
interpolated so here I'm telling I my
prompt is here is a poem in the style of
poet and right before Jupiter AI sends
my prompt to the Upstream language model
it will it will look into Python
namespace and say hey is there any
variable with the name poet and it says
yes it sees that there was a variable
defined and it will automatically
substitute the value of that variable
into the prompt
um
and the reason this is useful is because
it allows you to do some pretty
interesting stuff with rapid debugging
so here
in the very top top right I have a code
cell that says assert round 12.5 minus
round eleven not five is equal to one
and if this is false please throw
exception that's what the assert
statement means and for those unfamiliar
the round function is a standard Library
python function that just rounds a
floating point to the nearest integer so
to my uh astonishment when I run this
cell I actually get this assertion error
which means that this is somehow not
true how could this possibly not be true
you round 12.5
like whether you round it up or down it
should the difference should always be
one right so here we can actually use
IPython interpolation to help us debug
this because by default IPython
automatically caches all of your inputs
and outputs into dictionaries for easy
referencing and they are very
appropriately named in and out that's
actually what the um the number next to
every one of the cells in a Jupiter
notebook represents when you run a cell
it gets cached into the in dictionary
that is indexed by a not an integer so
here I can actually
I can actually ask chat GPT hey can you
explain why this code the Python 3 code
is failing and then inject the contents
of my previous cell into the prompt so
here you can see that in curly braces I
have referenced the in dictionary at
index 2 which contains the contents of
the previous cell I just run and here
chat GPA is able to explain to me why
this is failing and it says this is
failing because Python 3 uses Bankers
rounding which means that odd and even
numbers are actually rounded differently
to prevent bias pretty incredible I had
no idea about that but um yeah and it
even it even goes for the extra credit
and it tries to give you some code that
uh that should pass the assertion and to
my astonishment when I run that code it
passes as expected so very impressive
stuff
next I want to talk about another
feature Jupiter AI offers in Jupiter lab
which is the chat panel
so how to chat with Jupiter AI the
Jupiter AI package automatically
provides a lab extension that offers a
chat panel in the left sidebar so this
is the same location where the file
browser lives you just click on the
button and it opens up a chat panel and
the chat panel allows you to have a
conversational interaction with a
language model which previously was
usually exclusive to web playgrounds
um not many people have built these
conversational interfaces
um and this chat panel also supports a
lot Tech and markdown rendering really
nice so here for example I'm using the
jupyter AI chat panel and asking what is
the 2D LaPlace equation oh I definitely
don't know and uh
Jupiter AI gives me a very coherent and
well-formatted response thanks to
Jupiter AI
Jupiter AI also supports chat memory
built in and you know this might not be
that exciting to those who exclusively
play with chat GPT but most language
models are essentially what we call
One-Shot models or state they're
essentially stateless between
invocations
um so if you ask a question about cars
and then you receive a response from the
model you ask a follow-up question using
the same API oftentimes it will have no
idea what you're talking about because
it has no memory of the previous
conversational exchange so what Jupiter
AI does is that we are using a
third-party library for language models
called Lang chain and we are using Lane
chain agents and conversational memory
objects to essentially automatically
inject the history the chat history the
transcript back into the prompt so even
one shot in stateless models will be
able to have context they will you will
be able to ask follow-up questions so
here in this example I am asking can you
solve the equation with the finite
difference method instead and if Jupiter
AI had if I was using a language model
that was only exclusively stateless and
only support a One-Shot inference
the language model would say something
along the lines of I have no idea what
you're talking about right but
thankfully with the Jupiter AI uh
basically helps the language model
Remember by injecting the transcript
back into the prompt
um and this circles back to that idea of
being as vendor neutral as possible not
only are we allowing users to use
multiple models we actually go out of
our way to make it easier for users to
use multiple models
Jupiter AI chat also supports selections
so
um you can include selections with your
prompt or replace an existing selection
with the output of a model or you can do
both simultaneously really cool
um I tried making this image smaller but
it really just like it just kind of has
to be like this so please work with me
here
um but on the right side you can see
that I have a notebook open and I
selected a cell in this cell basically
visualizes the uh the images in my
pytorch training set and here I select
the contents of that cell and right
underneath the chat chat input at the
very bottom you can see two chaps you
can see two check boxes include
selection and replace selection and when
I click include selection I can ask a
question like hey I'm trying to
visualize the images in my Pi torch date
training set why am I not seeing
anything when I run this cell right and
I and before I send the message I make
sure to click include selection and then
I click and then I uh input shift enter
and it automatically sends it to the
jupyter AI chat and you can see there my
selection is being included in the
prompt and then Jupiter AI responds well
it's because you didn't call plot.show
and it actually provides a sample uh
that includes that does call that method
and that that code does work
Jupiter AI also all sports real-time
collaboration with multiple users and an
AI simultaneously so Jupiter so multiple
um users can connect to a Jupiter lab
server and basically play around with a
language model simultaneously and in the
same Chat bar so when user a sends a
message user B will actually see user
A's message in the um in the in their
respective chat panel so here in this
example I have user a and user a asks
for a one-liner that adds the element of
a list together and Jupiter AI of course
is able to handle handle such a simple
request
but then user B pops into the chat and
asks does that work with python 2 and
Jupiter AI is able to respond to that as
well and say yes this this also works
with python too so the key the key idea
here is that
Jupiter real-time collaboration with
Jupiter AI allows peers and co-workers
to ask follow-up questions to The Prompt
that you may have sent
so here is a more fun example
um user a asks why is my configuration
not forwarding the host name to the
server and the user is using the
selection interface to include this to
include the configuration into the
prompt
and then the AI is able to respond with
a coherent answer and then let's say
user B also works at the same company
connect and is connected to the same
jupyter lab server but they're based out
of France so then user B asks
francaise I don't know if I said that
correctly I definitely didn't
um and then jifter AI is actually able
to respond in French so this is a really
cool and exciting way of getting
this is a really exciting feature
because it highlights how collaboration
can really be taken to the next level by
adding an AI in between like the AI can
perform auxiliary functions that your
peers may not be able to do so and the
AI is also always available generally so
there's no worrying about time zones
when collaborating with an AI
Jupiter AI also allows you to generate
notebooks this is a really exciting
feature that K that um that we've worked
really hard on recently but you can use
the slash generate slash command to
generate a Notebook based on a prompt so
to use the slash command it's kind of
like slack or Discord where you just
start your input with the slash command
and then the rest of it are any
arguments or the rest of the prompt so
here in the example
user a asks generate a notebook that
explains how matplotlib works and in
Jupiter AI basically crunches on that
and then actually saves a new notebook
in the user's current directory
um and the way we're doing this is that
the Jupiter AI backend actually
decomposes this really complex task into
multiple smaller ones
so for example if you just told a
language model generate me a notebook
and give me the entire Json file all at
once pretty much all language models
maybe with the exception of Jeep G4
would fail at that mainly due to
technical limitations concerning a
maximum prompt size and output size so
what we're doing in the back end is we
take this tab we take a complex task and
we break it down imperatively and we we
that is all declared in the code itself
so basically there is a separate and
each of these like smaller tasks each of
these smaller discrete separate tasks
are processed by Lane chain agents that
run in parallel by wrapping the lane
chain agent and array actor now that's a
lot of that's a lot of words but
basically what this means is the title
so we first generate the title in the
description and and the outline and then
from that outline that outline is
basically a table of contents so it has
multiple sections in it and for each of
those sections that now is like this
basically stateless task that can be
executed in a in a language model so
that portion can actually be entirely
parallelized which is really really cool
so to show you this is actually the
notebook that was generated using
Jupiter AI
um as you you can actually verify that
this is a real screenshot because the
file names do match so
to highlight the intro
so Jupiter AI will generate a title and
it will also generate some descriptions
so for example this notebook was created
by Jupiter AI with the following prompt
this again circles back to the big idea
concerning transparency and traceability
we know like we go pro we proactively
informed a user when we are generating
AI generated content and
the rest of the notebook looks like this
where each section contains a bunch of
code cells that you can run and
these coattails uh they do run and they
do provide a visual educational
experience for understanding how matplot
lib Works which is really exciting
because this has as you might imagine
tremendous potential in the space of
education and software development right
like imagine using this to help explain
to your peers how a certain python
Library works or use this to to go to
students and explain how how matplotlib
works
and we've actually taken this concept
and we've pushed it pretty far and
surprisingly
um
uh a lot of the current language models
are actually able to generate some
pretty sophisticated content using this
framework where again we are assisting
the language model by proactively
breaking down a really complex task into
smaller ones and sort of guiding the
language model to the correct answer so
this is actually available on the GitHub
repository under the examples directory
where um one of my colleagues generated
a notebook that teaches you how to train
a dense neural network with pytorch this
is Way Beyond My Level of expertise so
very impressive
um I did want to I also want to
highlight one of the key features of
Jupiter AI which is the allowing users
to question files via retrieval
augmented generation
so quick recap in embedding models and
fights so embedding models at a very
very very high level uh base map syntax
to a high dimensional Vector space that
we call an embedding space and the idea
is that once you transform this text
into this very like thousand-dimensional
vector nearby vectors indicate semantic
similarity so this can help this can
help find similar content
so for example the embeddings for dog
and canine should be very near of one
another
fice is a local Vector database or
approximate nearest neighbor Library
depending on how you look at it this
seems like a bit of a controversial
topic so I did give both sides of the
argument and Feist can basically index
embeddings like kind of like a database
really it can index embeddings and then
perform similarity search on another
embedding so for example I if I indexed
the embedding for a canine and I
searched dog it should return the
embedding for canine and the analogy
here is that Feist is kind of like a
local search engine
all right indexing files so you can
index a file tree recursively using the
slash learn slash command so the only
require the only positional argument is
the uh path to the directory from your
project root so here I'm doing slash
learn docs which means that I have a
directory in my in my project book
called docs and this is actually the
this is actually the documentation for
Jupiter AI so if you look at the file
path it's
um it's my workbook workspace and that's
actually the Jupiter AI repo and it's
actually indexing the documentation and
then Jupiter AI will respond
asynchronously I have indexed uh all the
documents and I'm ready to answer
questions about them
so what happens here is that files are
embedded via an embedding model and then
we index them via face
and Feist runs locally by the way so
that's another really nice thing it's
free it's the best price really
so questioning the index so you can use
the slash ask slash command to tell
Jupiter AI hey please use this index
when answering my next question so
so what happens here is that when you
send a prompt The Prompt gets uh
embedded via a embedding model and then
phyce performs a similarity search to
find relevant search results from all of
the index documents in your file tree so
so for example I here I'm asking Jupiter
AI about Jupiter AI which is pretty meta
what is Jupiter Ai and how can I install
it and keep in mind that if you tried
this with chat GPT right now it would
completely fail on you and why is that
is because language models typically
have a cutoff date for their training
data so the one for chat gbt I believe
is sometime in mid 2021 so anything
after that
chati has absolutely no idea what you're
talking about
but here because we previously indexed
all of the documentation for Jupiter AI
we can ask it questions about things it
wouldn't have known about so in other
words we are doing we are proactively
providing context to the language model
to help
so taking this concept a bit further you
can also ask some I've experimented with
this and it's actually pretty smart so
for example here I'm saying I'm getting
an unauthenticated exception when trying
to run a cell magic what authentication
am I supposed to provide when using the
open AI provider and if you didn't read
the documentation this might be a little
vague but Jupiter AI is able to respond
within a second and say you need to
specify the open AI API key and it
gathered this information by reading our
documentation
another and here you see another example
how do I get Jupiter AI to render output
with latex when running a cell magic and
we discussed this earlier but in case
you forgot Jupiter AI can also tell you
tell you about all about it again
all right so take away from this talk
Jupiter AI can provide code Insight it's
very good at explaining code especially
if you index them to local files it can
debug failing code very easily thanks to
magix and selections and all sorts of
utilities we're providing to users
Jupiter AI essentially is best described
if you had to describe Jupiter AI in a
single sentence Jupiter AI provides a
general interface for interaction and
experimentation with currently available
language models
Jupiter AI allows you to collaborate
with both peers and a language model
simultaneously in Jupiter lab which as
we have shown is actually pretty
powerful for certain applications
so
Jupiter AI well we're working very hard
on multi-model support oh
multi-modal model support wow that's a
that's a lot of words
um so for example text to image or image
to image right
um not just not just text to text but
pushing like trying to play with some
other generative AI models aren't just
loms
um it would also be really cool if
Jupiter AI could index Upstream
documentation so for example imagine a
world where you could have a
conversational interface to any python
library that you're using just by
providing the name of the Pi Pi package
and then jupyter AI goes to that website
finds the documentation page indexes it
recursively and then is able to ask
answer questions about it
um we're also working on we're also
working on model configurability in the
chat right now we are using the um
exclusively the open AI models for both
the embedding and the uh and the uh the
language model that's powering the chat
panel the reason we're doing this is
because right now there were still a few
issues with regards to how we're
generating The Prompt that not basically
different models kind of communicate
differently depending on how they're
trained and for some of these more
complex tasks we're still working on uh
making making it better for different
language models and we're also working
on much more
um so here is a a brief very brief beta
uh I actually just reviewed this pull
request yesterday
um
um yeah and uh we're already working on
multimodal models just to um put my
money where my mouth is right
so uh please check us out GitHub
um it's again it's under the Jupiter lab
sub project that's how you know it's
official
um well I guess you can't really click
that link but like try your best
um and uh documentation
um Jupiter ai.read.com stuff
um
acknowledgments thank you to my team at
AWS my manager is Brian Granger you may
have heard of him he is the co-founder
of project Jupiter really awesome guy
and I also like to thank my teammates
and co-workers at AWS Jason piyush and
Andre they've all contributed an
enormous amount of effort into this
um yeah so just big thank you to all of
them
and thank you to the audience for being
here thank you
[Applause]